what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today we have some pretty exciting news
for the daredevil fans out there a lot
of people very understandably might i
add were very upset when the daredevil
show ended on netflix but a couple of
years ago there were some rumblings that
perhaps some of these netflix characters
like all of the defenders might appear
in the mcu down the road and it looks
like we are finally there and if you're
wondering if he's going to be returning
in one project the answer is no he's
actually going to be returning in at
least four projects according to recent
reports and of course all of these
projects are going to take place inside
of the mcu one of these projects being
spider-man no way home of course and of
course i will break it all down
everything you need to know in this
video also still doing my spider-man
collectible giveaway all you got to do
to enter subscribe to my channel and the
other channel cosmic culture and leave
some comments on some recent videos to
enter so today's news is coming from the
account binge watch this who i can
confirm do have really good sources and
today they are confirming that charlie
cox will be returning as matt murdock
aka daredevil and four mcu projects big
big news now one of these projects kind
of doesn't count because one of them is
spider-man no way home it counts but
daredevil's not really going to appear
just matt murdock now i think everybody
at this point in time knows how this is
going to go down and spider-man no way
home at the end of spider-man far from
home mysterio outed peter parker and a
lot of people think that he killed
mysterio and tried to kill a lot of
other people so he's wanted and we know
that the police are indeed going to get
him and he's going to have to go face
trial of course he's going to need a
lawyer for this and what superhero what
blind superhero do we know that is a
lawyer in new york well jennifer walters
aka she-hulk but we'll talk about her in
just a bit but of course i am talking
about matt murdock daredevil himself
here's the deal though we're not going
to see him suit up in spider-man no way
home we're simply going to see matt
murdock he's just going to be playing
peter's lawyer however apparently there
is going to be a little bit of a node to
the fact that he is indeed daredevil now
according to binge watch this and
previous reports it is indeed going to
be charlie cox's matt murdock which i
know fans are insanely happy about so
he's going to be returning again in four
projects spider-man no way home is one
of them and a solo project is another
one as well according to bench watch
this that's right it appears that
daredevil is going to be getting his own
solo project probably on disney plus now
it's not confirmed to be on disney plus
it's just simply referred to as his own
solo outing so it very well could be a
movie but considering where the mc was
going right now i don't think there
would be a daredevil solo film
unfortunately but since he is appearing
in other disney plus shows he'll
probably get a show of his own
especially if you consider the fact that
fans actually really like the daredevil
netflix show a lot of people were
disappointed when it ended but now it
looks like it could be coming back to
life under the direction of kevin feige
the president of marvel studios the
mastermind behind the entire mcu so
daredevil is coming back and it looks
like he's going to be a lot better but
we are keeping charlie cox which is
fantastic now as far as what his solo
project could be about well it seems
like they're going to be setting that up
over the next couple of years because
another one of the four projects that
he's reported to be in is she-hulk now
she-hulk is coming in 2022 which means
we're going to be getting a decent
amount of matt murdock in the mcu within
a year's time span because he's going to
be in spider-man no way home and then in
she-hulk now matt murdock showing up in
she-hulk is kind of a no-brainer
jennifer walters is a lawyer and she's a
superhero she's she-hulk and she's in
new york so it would make sense that her
and matt murdock would run into each
other now at this point in time it is
not confirmed whether or not this is
just going to be a very quick cameo like
he's going to be in spiderman home or if
he's going to have some significant role
in the series if i had to take a guess i
would assume that he's probably just a
quick cameo maybe here and there maybe
in the courtroom somewhere i don't think
he's going to be putting on a suit and
going out with she-hulk fighting crime
unfortunately i think this is going to
be just a setup until he gets his own
project kevin feige mentioned recently
in an interview for the hawkeye press
junket that the shows really are focused
on who they're supposed to be about so
she-hulk is going to focus on she-hulk
this kind of goes back to the one
division days where myself and a lot of
other people thought that mephisto
really was coming in and then of course
she had paul bettany talking about some
mysterious big cameo that turned out
just to be himself but we all thought
somebody else was going to be coming in
and at the end it ended up just being
about wanda and vision and the villain
of course which was agatha harkness who
is getting her own disney plus show but
the point of the matter is these shows
are going to just stick to focusing on
their main characters there was no x-men
in the falcon and the winter soldier
which was a pretty big bummer since i
went to madrapore there was no mephisto
and loki or one division instead all of
these shows are simply focusing on what
their title is one division loki falcon
in the winter soldier and she-hulk so
i'm just gonna go ahead and assume that
daredevil's not suiting up and fighting
with she-hulk especially if you consider
the fact that mark ruffalo is returning
for the show this is confirmed and we've
even seen a picture of him and little
jennifer walters and we know that he's
not smart hulk anymore he has the
ability to go between bruce banner and
the hulk now so we already have two
hulks coming in she-hulk i'm gonna
assume that if they threw daredevil in
there in a fighting superhero manner it
would be a little bit too crowded but
don't worry because matt murdock is
going to be appearing in the echo series
according to binge watch this and this
has actually been reported for some time
now because along with matt murdock aka
daredevil it's also being reported that
kingpin is also going to return in the
echo series which makes a ton of sense
if you know the history of echo kingpin
and daredevil it's actually kind of a
messed up story here's a brief rundown
ekko aka maya lopez who will be
appearing in the hawkeye series this is
confirmed is the adoptive daughter of
kingpin and this comes in a very weird
way kingpin actually kills maya's father
willie crazy horse lincoln and he
actually dies in front of maya leaving a
handprint on her face but his last dying
wish was that kingpin raises her and
raises her well in this weird kind of
way kingpin actually honors this super
weird the guy that killed your dad has
now become your adopted dad not anything
i would want but anyways she's believed
to be mentally disabled but she's just
deaf but fisk sends her to an expensive
school for people with learning
disabilities but they quickly realized
that she is actually very very gifted
and they soon sent her to another
expensive school for prodigies now
kingpin eventually sends maya to kill
matt murdock telling her that matt
believes that william fisk is a bad
person and that she is actually the only
way to prove him wrong and due to all of
kingpin's lies she actually believes him
she believes that he's a good person
however her and matt murdock end up
falling in love now she doesn't know
that he's daredevil at the time she
would then go on to become echo and
she's tasked to hunt down daredevil and
she's a really good match for him but
she realizes something that he has
heightened senses and she quickly
realizes that he's blind so she
orchestrates a way to fight him in a way
that his senses are useless but right
before she's gonna kill him she
discovers that he is indeed matt murdock
her love from there matt murdock tells
her the truth about everything and she
realizes that fisk is obviously a
horrible person as if killing her father
wasn't enough however she would go on to
eventually shoot fisk in the face making
him blind so she gets a revenge and
there's a lot more story after that but
the main part of this story is that
clearly daredevil and matt murdock play
a huge role in ekko's life kingpin as
well he plays an insanely huge role in
meia's life and to not have both of
these two people in the echo series
would be kind of weird like insanely
weird if you're gonna tell her origin
story about how her dad dies and
everything then kingpin has to be in the
show and if daredevil is already in the
mcu at this point spider-man no way home
she-hulk possibly his own project but
i'm gonna go ahead and say that that's
coming after this but he'll be in the
mcu so it would make sense that he would
be a part of this as well since he is a
major part of her story so great news
for the daredevil fans not only is
daredevil coming to the mcu but he's
going to really be coming to the mcu
coming in three projects and then his
own solo project which is just fantastic
so let me know how excited you are about
the daredevil being in the mcu finally
let me know in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram twitter and tick tock as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you